في هذا المشهد المهجور المضحك ، لا توجد
خردة من الغطاء النباتي في الأفق ، يقع
مخيم مؤقت لبعض النازحين داخليًا في أفغانستان
بين سكانه البالغ من العمر تسع سنوات ، باوانا ،
لباسها الوردي المشرق من
الضحك وألعاب الطفولة ،
خدعة للأهوال التي تتكشف في هذا المكان غير
المضياف  البيئة
[موسيقى]
انتقلت عائلة بروانا إلى هذا المخيم في
محافظة بغديس قبل أربع سنوات بعد
أن فقد والدها وظيفته
، وهي مساعدة إنسانية وعمل وضيع يكسب
ثلاثة دولارات يوميًا لتوفير
المواد الأساسية للبقاء على قيد الحياة
ولكن منذ استيلاء طالبان
قبل شهرين ونصف.  جفت الأموال أو المساعدة
، ومع وجود ثمانية أفواه لإطعام والد باروانا
يقوم الآن بما لا يمكن تصوره
، ليس لدي عمل ولا نقود ولا طعام لا بد
لي من بيع ابنتي ، ويقول إنه ليس لدي
خيار آخر
يحلم بالذهاب إلى المدرسة وأن
أصبح مدرسًا  تضع المكياج
هواية مفضلة للفتيات الصغيرات لكن
بوانا تعرف أنها تستعد لما
ينتظرها
والدي باعني لأننا لا نفعل ذلك
تناول الخبز والأرز والدقيق ، لقد باعني
إلى رجل عجوز ، جاء
الرجل ذو اللحية البيضاء الذي يدعي أنه
يبلغ من العمر 55 عامًا
ليجمعها ، لقد اشترى باروانا مقابل 200000 أفغاني
ما يزيد قليلاً عن 2000 دولار أمريكي
تستر أنوات باروانا مثل والدتها
هذه  عروسك ، يرجى الاعتناء
بها ، يقول والد باوانا بالطبع سأعتني بردودها ، فالرجل
يمسك يده الكبيرة بإطارها الصغير
وهو يحمل حقيبتها الوحيدة
التي تقاوم مرة أخرى
حفر كعبيها في الأوساخ
لكن
المصير غير مجدٍ  من هذا الطفل الصغير الذي لا حول له ولا قوة
، فإن
زواج الأطفال ليس شيئًا جديدًا في
المناطق الريفية الفقيرة في أفغانستان ، لكن
نشطاء حقوق الإنسان يبلغون عن
حالات متزايدة بسبب الأزمة الاقتصادية
والإنسانية التي تجتاح
البلاد ،
فهذه قرارات مدمرة لا
يجب على أي والد أن يتخذها أبدًا.  وهو
يتحدث حقًا عما
يحدث الانهيار الاستثنائي في أفغانستان في
الوقت الحالي منذ شهور ، حيث كانت الأمم المتحدة
تحذر من كارثة.  غانا
، البلد المعتمد على المساعدات التي دمرتها الحرب ،
ينزلق في شتاء قاسٍ حيث
تم تجميد أصول البنك المركزي بمليارات الدولارات بعد وصول طالبان
إلى السلطة في آب / أغسطس ، مما أدى
إلى نفاد الأموال من الأجور التي لم يتم
دفعها لأشهر بينما ارتفعت أسعار المواد الغذائية
وفقًا لذلك.  بالنسبة للأمم المتحدة ، فإن أكثر من نصف
السكان لا يعرفون من أين تأتي وجبتهم التالية
، ويواجه أكثر من ثلاثة ملايين طفل
دون سن الخامسة
سوء تغذية حاد في الأشهر المقبلة ،
يحتاج سكان أفغانستان إلى شريان الحياة
، وبينما كان هناك مليار دولار
تعهد المانحون من الأمم المتحدة بمساعدة الشعب الأفغاني ،
حيث تم تلقي أقل من نصف هذه الأموال
حيث
توقف المجتمع الدولي عن الاعتراف
بحكومة طالبان ، سيموت شعب أفغانستان
من الجوع في
الشهرين المقبلين وليس فقط القليل من
هذا الأمر.  الناس أكثر وأكثر
عرضة للخطر ولا يمكننا قبول تلك
المشاعر التي يشاركها طالبان
، نطلب من وكالات الإغاثة العودة
إلى الأفغاني  n ومساعدة هؤلاء
الفقراء وإلا ستزداد الأزمة سوءًا
بالنسبة لهذه العائلة في مقاطعة جور المجاورة ،
فهم يحاولون بيع ابنتين
يبلغان من العمر تسعة أعوام وزيتون يبلغان من العمر أربع سنوات
مقابل ألف دولار أمريكي ،
هل تعرفين سبب ذلك.  إعادة
بيعك ، يسأل الصحفيون سيتان
لأننا عائلة فقيرة وليس
لدينا أي طعام نأكله ، تقول
هل أنت خائف هنا
نعم أنا
عائلة أخرى في مقاطعة جور اقترضت
أموالًا من جارها البالغ من العمر 70 عامًا
الآن وهو يطالب بإعادتها ولكن
ليس لديهم ما يعطونه
سوى ابنتهم البالغة من العمر 10 سنوات ، ماجال ،
ابنتي لا تريد الذهاب
وتبكي طوال الوقت أشعر بالخجل الشديد لدرجة أنه
يقول
مرعوبًا إنها تهدد بالقتل
إذا دفعوني للزواج من الرجل العجوز
سأفعل  اقتل نفسي ، لا أريد أن أترك
والدي
بعد أيام
، اكتشفت أن البيع قد
انتهى
لطفل أفغاني آخر تم بيعه في حياة
البؤس.